ich denke gerne daran hindern dass wir
in den vergangenen 15 monaten ungefähr
300 mal ich hab mal so grob überschlagen
ungefähr 300 mal den tag zusammen
begonnen haben ich spreche über unser
tägliches morgendliches telefonat zur
politischen lage nicht was jetzt denkt
es ist überhaupt keine lappalie ist er
sieht aus wie ein 12-jähriger und macht
herrenwitze wie ein 70-jähriger und das
ist bei ihm ein system so harte worte
von patricia wie fühlen sie sich wenn
sie so etwas hören bei mit kritik muss
man umgehen ich hatte mich ja auch
entschuldigt für die bemerkung weil sie
missglückt wahr und falsch aufgefasst
worden ist und damit meine ich muss man
in der politik meine öffentlichkeit
umgehen es gibt natürlich kritik die ist
treffend und manchmal ist eine kritik
auch ein bisschen selber merkwürdig aber
merkwürdig glaube ich gerade oder wie im
fall jahren ganz ehrlich ich hab mir
schon viele anderen müssen bin
fdp-vorsitzender ich bin leid und kummer
und storms gewohnt mein täglich brot nur
bei so einem ernsten thema wie sexismus
und chauvinismus sollte man so behutsam
argumentieren dass man nicht selbst beim
objekt der kritik auf äußerlichkeiten
geht und ich weiß nicht ob es ein
kompliment ist wenn man sagt ich sehe
aus wie ein 12-jähriger also ich muss
ihnen sagen das war tatsächlich
natürlich nicht als kompliment gemeint
ich habe das plakativ so formuliert und
ich will ihn erklären warum das was da
passiert ist hat in mir tatsächlich so
etwas wie wut als heute und zwar
stellvertretend für frauen denn wir
frauen sind tatsächlich fast täglich
oder wöchentlich auf jeden fall mit
einer regelmäßigkeit in der situation
dass wir witze hören die wir selber als
beleidigend empfinden aber vielleicht
nicht so gemeint sind dass wir in
situationen kommen
ich spreche nicht von diesen völlig klar
sexistischen situationen aber eben von
situationen
die so ein bisschen
interpretationsspielraum haben die aber
als frau sehr sehr schmerzhaft sind
insofern mein ziel war in das plakativ
zu zeigen nicht mit den eigenen waffen
schlagen aber zumindest zu zeigen wie
sehr man da zu treffen ist könnte diese
diese wut von frauen nachvollziehen über
vielleicht manche dinge die für menschen
als kleinigkeit gelten aber m für frauen
wirklich eine große und auch er eine
große bedeutung haben also was ihren
satz angeht schwamm drüber
was das grundlegende problem angeht ja
dafür habe ich verständnis und dafür
brauchen wir auch eine andere form des
umgangs und zwar in doppelter hinsicht
zum einen finde ich brauchen wir eine
kultur des ehrlichen und offenen
feedbacks das heißt frauen oder in
anderer konstellation auch männer müssen
offen artikulieren wenn sie sich in
ihren gefühlen verletzt fühlen oder sich
zum beispiel in eine rolle gedrängt
fühlen
am besten wäre es
ich kann damit umgehen aber ich denke
jetzt an die die konkrete situation im
büro wo jemand ebenfalls nicht aus bösem
motiven sondern aus mangelnder
sensibilität oder warum auch immer eine
missglückte bemerkung macht dann muss
sie oder er ja nicht sofort komplett
verdammt werden so das muss eine form
des feedbacks geben die selbstkorrektur
erlaubt das also jemand etwas selbst aus
der welt schaffen kann oder sein
verhalten verändert das heißt die
offenheit auf der einen seite ein fehler
zu benennen
aber auf der anderen seite auch eine
möglichkeit des verzeihens bei dieser
lassen sich aus den einsatz marianne
machen mit ja schon wie ein mann immer
unterbrechen mit denen dieser sendung
nicht so gehen haben eine ganz andere
debattenkultur
also feedback offenheit ansprechen was
einen verletzten zugleich
selbstkorrektur bei anderen ermöglichen
ich glaube wir brauchen aber auch
institutionelle absicherungen dafür also
zum beispiel wir in unserer partei
ich habe seinerzeit mal schon zwei jahre
her ein prozess angestoßen und genau
diesen chauvinismus im alltag anzugehen
und wir haben dafür ein system von
vertrauensleuten geschaffen an die kann
sich jemand wenden
oft genug sind es ja dann frauen und
kann sich anonym wenn und kann sagen da
gibt es den so und so und so der macht
regelmäßig dies und das
wie gesagt es geht nicht um sexuelle
belästigung sondern es geht um das was
weit davor ist alleine schon der onkel
hafte alte witz den man schon seit
jahrzehnten eigentlich zum kotzen findet
der aber immer wieder konnten sie nicht
ich finde das ist wieso bist du
plötzlich persönlich dass der altherren
witz der letztlich traurigerweise von
einem ganzen parteitag über geblieben
ist eigentlich gezeigt hat dass das da
auch bedient worden ist also das was du
quasi auch kritisierst oder wo du eben
sagst das gehen wir an dass das auf
jeden fall sozusagen vielleicht eine
bemerkung war also auch mit der kunst
pause dazwischen die reaktion von den
berg um sie dieses jahr also da in der
aussage war eine reaktion darauf dass
sie sich sozusagen dabei unwohl gefühlt
hat ist das nicht schade oder kann man
da nicht auch so sagen die selbstkritik
am tag legen zu sagen okay das hätte ich
besser machen müssen
aber ich habe mich doch bei der ersten
gelegenheit am montag danach
entschuldigt für diese missglückte
bemerkung ich will eins aber schon sagen
und das ist das was ich mit der
offenheit für feedback aber andererseits
auch meine mit der möglichkeit der
selbstkorrektur
ich habe mich schon ein bisschen
gewundert was für eine sexismus debatte
danach losgetreten worden ist muss das
ganz offen so sagen werden
hundertprozentig ja weil man muss doch
immer schauen in welchem kontext
passiert etwas mit welchem motiv
passiert etwas also geht es darum macht
auszudrücken jemanden hier eine frau
klein zu machen oder geht es darum eine
sehr unangenehme sensible situation
nicht zu einer trauerfeier werden zu
lassen und ist es der versuch etwas
aufzulockern das heißt die frage kontext
die frage motiv muss gestellt werden und
ich habe mich seinerzeit sehr gefreut
dass nicht irgendjemand aus meiner
partei sondern die kollegin dorothea von
der csu
nicht öffentlich verteidigt hat und
gesagt hat man muster beim sexismus
fragen ob das bei einem mann system hat
oder nicht
und ich finde da die europäer von einem
politischen mitbewerber auch eine größe
gezeigt die ich mit insgesamt wünsche
für diese ganz für unsere zukunft und
das zusammenleben in unserer
gesellschaft enorm wichtige und sensible
debatte aber wenig kennt der weiß das ja
auch und das würde ich dir zum beispiel
auch nicht unterstellen trauer stehen
ich hast du mich in ruhe auf den hals
trotzdem habe ich das gesagt was ich
heute auch sage fand es unglücklich dass
diese altherren wird zustande gekommen
ist weil ich glaube ist es besser kannst
und weil es ja nicht das erste mal war
das zweite mal der satz ist ja schon mal
genauso gefallen im zusammenhang mit
claudia roth und dafür die ich schon
dass du natürlich auch als paar jahre
vorher genau drei jahre vorher aber er
ist ja gefallen aber dass ich
unterbrechen ganz kurz und dass man ein
bisschen weiter zu tragen ich finde aber
auch mittlerweile dass wir doch
eigentlich wir sind was
gleichberechtigung betrifft leider nicht
so weit wie man sich das vielleicht
manchmal ein bildet oder gerne hätte ich
finde aber dass man durchaus so das habe
ich auch damals in der sendung hatte
ging es darum märz um seine kommentare z
es gibt schon dem moment wo man einfach
mal drüber lächeln kann und darüber
stehen kann also das waren so ein dass
man so laut sein
ich kann euch da einfach nichts für mich
finden aber dass es viel zu viel
aufmerksamkeit geschenkt wird mein gott
der hat es war es lustig nein es war
nicht lustig passiert es ja es passiert
und jetzt also ich bin damit das aber
ich finde mit dem argument und mit der
haltung komme ja kein stück weiter so
wie die sache aber dass sie dabei das
von beispielsweise jahrhundertelang
männer sich sozusagen selbst gerecht
bevorteilt haben was das dritte album
von bisherigen geschichtlich und
christian linder es geht um das land
geht strukturelle gerade problem und die
herausforderung der gleichberechtigung
das ist schwierig finde wenn du jemanden
absprechen willst wie er sich gefühlt
hat ob es sexismus ist oder nicht dass
muss die betroffene folge moment
versprochen ich weiß wie sie sich in dem
moment gefühl hat ich kann nur davon
ausgehen wie ich mich fühlen wird und
ich würde denken und weiter werk
gesprochen ist das alles verziehen
und kann sie sagen das ist ein witz oder
hat sie ihnen gesagt fand ich jetzt
nicht so elegant
ich habe die nasen liegt jetzt im laden
aus bilateralen kontakten berichte ich
nicht aber es war die schwierige
situation ist doch völlig klar ich
musste aus unterschiedlichen politischen
erwägungen das amt der unseres
generalsekretärs neu besetzen
und die hatte für den daad heute berg
den vorschlag gemacht eine andere
führungsposition einzunehmen den
vorschlag hat sie abgelehnt
dann muss man eine kollegin dann auch
verabschieden in einem parteitag das ist
eine sehr schwierige situation weil ich
möchte ja weiter dass sie in unserer
partei eine wichtige rolle spielt wie
schätzen sie auch als persönlichkeit
dennoch war die neubesetzung nötig und
deshalb wollte ich die situation dort
auflockern
ich habe den wohnwert ich im grunde
wollte ich folgendes zum auszuwählen
kann das je mehr jetzt wenn sie sagen
aus dem nähkästchen
es wurde immer so erzählt in berlin das
wort heute berg und ich gar keinen
persönlichen kontakt hätten
und ich habe überlegt bei der
verabschiedung dieses gerücht dass
gestreut wird unter journalisten das
entkräftet du alleine durch den hinweis
dass wir eben jeden morgen um 9 uhr 30
unsere gemeinsame telefonschalte haben
übrigens auch mit den mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeitern jeden morgen gibt es
die möglichkeit zum austausch und da ich
immer freie rede und in 70 minuten liebe
diesen gelingt nicht jede formulierung
wenn man nämlich kein blatt dabei hat
dann ist manches etwas ungelenk wir
legen ungelenk aber trotzdem fehler
können passieren
nur was und jetzt rede ich auch mal
erlaube ich mir wie du nicht von mir und
der situation zu reden warum gehen wir
in unserer gesellschaft mit fehlern so
um dass sie ganz schnell genutzt werden
jemanden komplett charakterlich
abzuurteilen ich persönlich wurde von
leuten abgeurteilt die mich noch nie
getroffen haben
und da werden dann werden dann dann kann
ich also geradezu karikaturen von einem
gezeigt und ich meine du sagst ja selber
du kennst mich du warst mit german dream
zuerst bei mir im podcast sie haben
schon privat uns beim abendessen
getroffen in größeren kreisen also hat
man ja ein bild von jemanden und da fand
ich wie gesagt ist
ja man könnte auch einfach sagen ich
kenne ihn dass es ihm passiert kümmern
wir uns jetzt um den wirklichen 6
[Musik]